la semaine dernière les candidats de top
wave sont allés de surprise en surprise
vas-y bienvenus ils ont d'abord tenté
d'impressionner notre jury de walle en
se posant dans le trou mais bon
franchement bastien j'ai cru pas fait le
taff et tout mais après erreur d'obolo
ce parce que l'offre et wesh qu'ils
soient dans le bus sur un scooter ya pas
de casque ils respectent rien
désolé wesh excuse pas dans l'épreuve de
rattrapage
guillaume elodie bastien et david rheem
tout donner en accostant une fille à la
manière des plus grands wesh wesh moi je
te parle pour moi franchement téphras
j'avoue heureusement david il a vraiment
fait défaut bonne journée
un faux pas qui l'écoutera sa place dans
l'aventuré un [ __ ] on arrive à un
stade de la compétition opus permettre
de se passer heure pareille aujourd'hui
dans top os nos candidats vont devoir
rivaliser de créativité et d'inventivité
puisqu'il s'apprête à revisiter l'un des
grands classiques wesh sur vecta king
guillaume comment vous allez aborder
cette épreuve à l'enrobage français
partir sur une belle paire de nike
requin et je vais la sublime et récupère
de chaussettes loto pour jouer sur la
connaissance des classiques d'accord
perdez pas tangué au moins 120 101 ghazi
l'asie
tu fais quoi là j'allais partir sur
peut-être un sur baisse pas les yeux ne
baisse pas les yeux et et une batterie à
bout quoi pardon oui je suis pas tout à
fait un bonhomme qui chamboule bunawan
on aime internet moisi fait la ceinture
bauchi dépit deux sans toi et en
produits que j'ai l'habitude de
travailler c'est partir là dessus
j'avoue j'ai ajouté un ingrédient
ministère ont pas aidé au jeudi passé
quoi je parle
non les gars marié la visière la côte
c'est à ça que je suis tombé le dis
franchement c'est malin moi j'aime bien
une tarte un beau gosse comme on en voit
pas souvent mon agressivité a su si
j'arrive pas la meta alan merde j'ai
décidé de la jouer en finesse avec un
trait de rasoir dans le sourcil et après
je vais dresser mois au dessus avec
façon bapt ou fragiles et ben voilà il a
voulu faire travailler original mais là
rien compris ces fiches à 2 ouf
allez plus que quelques secondes ou la
banane
j'ai c'est qu'il a pris la banane
biomédecine de passemar bol aussi par le
temps cette foire allez on finit on
finit vite vite on se dépêche et
top c'est fini tout le monde lave les
mains on lève les mains en l'air la
voilà à quoi dans speed je me suis
précipitée et je fais un trou de
boulettes dans mon polo lacoste à vue
j'espère que jury va pas trop me
victimise et tu vois les preuves de tous
les défis et de toutes les audaces c'est
ce soir dans top wesh
à suivre sur m6 un nouveau numéro de
wesh toute nue